اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في مقابله خاصه
يسرني ان استضيف رايدي الفضاء السعوديين
ريان برناوي وعلي القرني اهلا بكم اهلا
بكم شكرا صحه الحديث عن هذه المهمه
التاريخيه يعطيكم العافيه طبعا بالتاكيد
نقاط كثيره راح نتكلم عنها لكن خلوني ابدا
من حيث انتهيتما هنا في السعوديه قبل
المغادره التقيتم بوري العهد السعودي
بالتاكيد اللقاء كان مهم بالنسبه لكم قبل
المغادره ريان ابدا معاكي
كيف شفت اللقاء لماذا خرجت من هذا اللقاء
مساء الخير استاذ حسن ومساء الخير على
جميع المشاهدين
يعني رحلتنا هذه المره كانت مختلفه نحن
جينا على استقبال ولي العهد لنا ففي
البدايه اود ان اتقدم بجزيل الشكر
والعرفان لولي العهد ورئيس مجلس رئيس
المجلس الاعلى للفضاء لاستقباله لنا الحمد
لله كلمات مو كانت كانها دافع لنا يعني
تحمسنا وتزيدنا تفاؤل ان احنا ننفذ هذه
المهمه باذن الله على اكمل وجه وفي نفس
الوقت كان ياكد لنا دعمه واهتمامه ولا
محدود بمجال الفضاء وانه هو دائما معانا
في كل خطوه وانه باذن الله هذا احدى
مشاريع الرؤيه
فهدفنا باذن الله في هذه المرحله هو تعزيز
مكانه المملكه عالميا في مجال استكشاف
الفضاء خصوصا في خدمه البشريه
فباذن الله الان انا وعلي
واخواننا
رواد الفضاء الاخرين نحس بجاهزيتنا نحس
انه نحن الان جاهزين نحط بصمه المملكه في
مجال الفضاء وانه المملكه لازم تكون في
خارطه الدول اللي تتنافس وتستثمر في مجال
الفضاء فالحمد لله كان استقباله لنا اجمل
دافع واجمل دعم لنا
اتشرفنا صراحه بلقاء سمو الامير محمد بن
سلمان ولي العهد حفظه الله قائد النهضه
اللي نعيش فيها حاليا كلمات التحفيزيه
شجعنا وايدنا ان نروح ونواصل رؤيه المملكه
واهتمامها باستكشاف الفضاء واتاحه الفضاء
لمشاركه العلماء السعوديين بمشاركه
تجاربهم ان شاء الله في امه محطه الفضاء
الدوليه ريان اعود لك ربما من ابرز
الاسئله او كمدخل ايضا
لحظات الاولى تلقيتي فيها خبر اختيارك
كرائده فضاء سعوديه
نعيش معك هذا الجو وكيف كانت رده الفعل
بالنسبه لك والله استاذ حسن كان بالنسبه
لي يوم استثنائي في حياتي يعني يوم ما
تلقيت الخبر انا الى الان اعجز اني الاقي
كلمات توصف شعوري هذاك الوقت حماس تفاؤل
فخر اعتزاز يعني
بحاجه احسها تفوق الوصف يعني
احس كاني اتذكر موقف كانه صار امس يعني
كنت مستعده لابسه الباطل البالط حق
المختبر حقي وخلص طالعه من البيت رايحه
على دوامي
وصلني اتصال يعني فرديت طلع الاتصال من
الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء
فاول ما كلموني قالوا لي ريانه انت الان
صرتي اقرب للحلم مبروك تم اختيارك كاول
رائده فضاء السعوديه تذهب لمحطه الفضاء
الدوليه يعني الجمله لحالها خلاص يعني صرت
ماني عارفه دحين اروح الدوام ولا اخذ
اجازه لان الان رائده فضاء او باحثه ما
صرت عارفه يعني كيف اتصرف انا بحكم عملي
في مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي انا اسكن في
الرياض واهلي في جده فاحد الاشخاص اللي
مهمين بالنسبه لي هي ستي ام الوالده كنت
حابه اني انا اقول لها الخبر وهي بجده
فطلعت على الغرفه جلست على السرير اتصلت
على العمل وطلبت يوم اجازه واخذت تذكره من
الرياض لجده بس عشان ابلغها هذه الخبر
العظيم رده الفعل بالتاكيد كانت كبيره جدا
كانت لا توصف علي
اكيد خضعته لتدريبات كثيره في لانجاز هذه
المهمه ابرز الاشياء اللي خضعته لها حتى
يتم تاهيلكم بشكل كامل طبعا ولله الحمد
اتمنى مؤخرا اجمال التدريبات المتعلقه
بالرحله وكانت بشكل عام التدريب على
المهام اليوميه التشغيليه لمحطه الفضاء
الدوليه تدربنا على مركزين الابحاث
الاوروبي والياباني كذلك
التدريبات مجملتا على كيفيه التعايش داخل
المحطه الفضاء الدوليه وكذلك محاكاه
للانطلاق والعوده التدرب على الادوات اللي
بنستخدمها ان شاء الله في الابحاث العلميه
والابحاث
العمليه ان شاء الله على متن المحطه
هذه التدريبات بشكل عام تثبت او او تمكننا
من القدره على النجاح في هذه المهمه وكذلك
بعد المهمه ان شاء الله نعود الى ارض
الوطن محققين جميع الاهداف المرجوه من هذه
الرحله بالتاكيد هناك عديد من التجارب
والمهام اللي راح تؤ في الفضاء لو ندخل في
بعض تفاصيل هذه التجارب بالنسبه لكم
اصلا مهمتنا بالاساس هي مهمه علميه فباذن
الله سنقوم باجراء 14 تجربه علميه بحثيه
رائده يعني لاول مره في التاريخ باذن الله
هذه التجارب تعنى بمجالات متعدده اولها هي
ثلاث تجارب توعويه تعليميه ستكون
لها علاقه بالتعاون مع الطلاب فهذه
التجارب كلها هدفها تحفيز الطلاب وتحفيز
الفضول لديهم في مجال الفضاء وباذن الله
سنقوم باجراء اربع تجارب علميه لها علاقه
بالخلايا المناعيه وهذه باذن الله حتكون
اول مره في التاريخ سنقوم بزراعه خلايا
مناعيه في بيئه الجاذبيه الصغرى بحيث انه
نزرع الخلايا ونضيف علاجات مختلفه عليها
ونشوف مدى استجابتها في بيئه الجاذبيه
الصوره البحث لاول مره يجرى في التاريخ
بدعم سمو سيدي حفظه الله احب اضيف على
كلام زميلتي ريان انه سوف نقوم باجراء سته
تجارب في الطب البشري وهذا التجارب تعنى
بدراسه التغيرات على التي قد تصيب الدماغ
الجهاز العصبي العظام وكذلك النظر هذه
الدراسات سبق وتم اجرائها في بيئه
الجاذبيه الصغرى ولكن الجديد انه سوف يتم
استخدام اجهزه جديده لاول مره في الفضاء
بشانها المساعده في تسريع النتائج
والتحاليل ان شاء الله وكذلك في الاستمطار
الصناعي وهذه تجربه فيزيائيه تعتبر كاول
مره تحدث كذلك في الفضاء وهي من شانها او
كفيله نتائج هذه التجربه بزياده ورفع
كفاءه الاستمطار الصناعي في الارض من 15%
الى اكثر من 50% ان شاء الله وسوف تساعدنا
باذن الله في الاسهام على مكافحه التصحر
ومشاريع السعوديه لرؤيه 2030 مثل الرياض
الخضراء والشرق الاوسط الاخضر باذن الله
ريانه بصفتك اول رائده فضاء سعوديه ممكن
الرساله اللي ممكن تقدميها للمواطنات
السعوديات بعد هذه التجربه بالتاكيد اللي
يمكن الكثير ما كان متوقع انه ممكن يتم
انجازها خلال هذه الفتره القصيره صحيح هي
فعلا تجربه كبيره يعني شخصيا انا احس
بالفخر ولكن كميه مسؤوليه عاليه كوني اول
رائده فضاء سعوديه لكن هذا الشيء ايش
يورينا يورينا ثقه قيادتنا الرشيده فانه
المراه السعوديه تقدر تعمل في جميع
المجالات وايمانهم انهم هم لهم دور جدا
كبير في تنميه الوطن وبناء الوطن باذن
الله
بالعكس انصح الجميع باستغلال جميع الفرص
المتاحه لجميع السعوديات باذن الله لانه
كل الاحلام الان مدعومه كل شيء متوفر نحن
في عصر التمكين وعصر الازدهار دورنا فقط
نرفع شان المملكه عاليا باذن الله ايضا
على القرني بالتاكيد بالنسبه لك انت ايضا
هذه الرحله
امر كبير جدا وبالتالي كل ما يمكن انجازه
خلال هذه الرحله
يعتبر بالنسبه لك شيء عظيم رسالتك للشباب
السعودي مع هذه الرحله منذ البدايه وحتى
النهايه ان شاء الله انا كشاب سعودي وتيحت
لهذه الفرصه احب ان اوجه رساله لاخواني
واخواتي السعوديين احنا نعيش حاليا وقت
حاسم في المملكه العربيه السعوديه وبنقوم
بمهمه تاريخيه للمملكه بالذهاب الى محطه
الفضاء الدوليه كاول سعوديين على متنها
وهذه مهمه تمثل خطوه كبيره جدا في اطار
بناء جيل جديد من القاده والمستكشفين
والعلماء والباحثين ويجب علينا ان نكون
مصدر الهام الاجيال في الوطن العربي الى
افاق جديده تساعد البشريه على الاستفاده
من التجارب في الفضاء وكذلك يجب على كل
شاب وشابه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
حاليا ان يكون عند حسن ظن قيادتنا
وتطلعاتهم فينا وانه يجب علينا ان نحمل
ونضع المملكه العربيه السعوديه على خارطه
الدول المتقدمه باظهار مدى تقدمنا
بالتكنولوجيا والابحاث والعلوم ان شاء
الله كل التوفيق اتمنى لكم ان شاء الله
خلال هذه المهمه انتم ايضا وطاقم العمل
ربما ان شاء الله نلتقيكم بعد عودتكم الى
ارض الوطن سالمين باذن الله شكرا لكم انتم
ايضا مشاهدينا الكرام الى اللقاء لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار البرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات